♪ ♪
>> Chris: OUR NEXT GUEST HAS
CALLED THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION’S IMMIGRATION
PLAN RECRUIT AND RELEASE.
JOINING US NOW, ARCING,
ARKANSASSENATOR TOM COTTON.
WELCOME BACK.
>> Senator Cotton: GOOD TO BE
ON WITH YOU, CHRIS.
>> Chris: YOU JUST WATCHED MY
INTERVIEW WITH SECRETARY
MAYORKAS, YOUR REACTION, SIR?
>> Senator Cotton: CHRIS, IT’S
RICH THAT SECRETARY MAYORKAS
WON’T LET PRESS TRAVEL WITH HIM
TO THE BORDER, BUT HE WILL COME
ON YOUR SUNDAY MORNING SHOW AND
PEDDLE THE SAME KIND OF NONSENSE
THAT HAS CREATED THE BIDEN
BORDER CRISIS IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
I MEAN, HE’S BASICALLY SAYING
THE UNITED STATES WILL NOT
SECURE OUR BORDER AND THAT IS A
BIG WELCOME SIGN TO MIGRANTS
FROM ACROSS THE WORLD.
>> Chris: SO YOU SAY THAT YOU
HAVE THREE SIMPLE SOLUTIONS.
WHAT ARE THEY?
>> Senator Cotton: YEAH,
CHRIS, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
KEEPS SAYING THAT TRUMP SOMEHOW
DISMANTLED THE IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
THAT’S FALSE.
IT WAS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
THAT DISMANTLED THREE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE POLICIES.
FIRST, THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EXCLUSIONARY ORDER.
THEY LIFTED THAT ORDER AS IT
RELATES TO MINORS.
WELL, GUESS WHAT WE HAVE NOW
WITH THE BORDER?
LOTS MORE MINORS.
THAT’S NOT A SURPRISE.
SECOND, THE "REMAIN IN MEXICO"
POLICY.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WORKED
WITH THE GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO TO
ALLOW MIGRANTS WHO SHOWED UP ON
OUR BORDER TO MAKE AN ASYLUM
CLAIM BUT REMAIN IN MEXICO WHILE
WE ADJUDICATED RATHER THAN JUST
RELEASING THEM INTO THE COUNTRY
AND THIRD, THE SO-CALLED SAFE
THIRD COUNTRY AGREEMENT WITH
COUNTRIES LIKE GUATEMALA THAT
SAYS IF YOU PASS THROUGH A
COUNTRY THAT’S NOT YOUR OWN
SEEKING ASYLUM, YOU HAVE TO MAKE
THAT ASYLUM CLAIM WHEN THE FIRST
COUNTRY TO PASS THROUGH.
THAT’S THE INTERNATIONAL NORM,
THAT’S WHAT WE SHOULD DO.
JOE BIDEN COULD REIMPOSE ALL
THREE OF THOSE THINGS THIS WEEK
IF YOU WANTED TO.
>> Chris: ONE OF THE THINGS I
WAS STRUCK BY AT THE END OF THE
INTERVIEW, SECRETARY MAYORKAS
SAID "THE BORDER IS SECURE, THE
BORDER IS CLOSED."
IS IT?
>> Senator Cotton: NO, CHRIS,
OF COURSE NOT.
THEY MAY SIMPLY START PROCESSING
PEOPLE INTO THE COUNTRY WITHOUT
EVEN GIVING THEM A NOTICE TO
APPEAR IN COURT AND OF COURSE
ALL OF THESE BOGUS ASYLUM CLAIMS
ARE TAKING UP SO MUCH MANPOWER
AND RESOURCES OF THE BORDER,
THAT MEANS THAT WE ALSO HAVE
OTHER THREATS, LIKE INCREASES IN
FENTANYL AND OTHER KINDS OF DRUG
TRAFFICKING OR PERSONS ON THE
TERRORIST WATCH LIST CROSSING
THE BORDER.
THE BORDER RIGHT NOW IS WIDE
OPEN BECAUSE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DISMANTLED THE
VERY EFFECTIVE POLICIES OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND THE
AGREEMENTS WE HAD WITH MEXICO
AND OTHER LATIN AMERICAN
COUNTRIES.
>> Chris: I WANT TO TURN TO
ANOTHER SUBJECT, SENATOR .
YOU’VE VOTED AGAINST THE
$1.9 TRILLION COVID RELIEF
PACKAGE, AND I WANT TO PUT UP
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT IT WOULD
DO FOR ARKANSAS.
IT WOULD PROVIDE STIMULUS
PAYMENTS OF UP TO $1400 TO 93%
OF ADULTS IN YOUR STATE AND 94%
OF CHILDREN IN YOUR STATE.
IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE
$1.2 BILLION FOR SCHOOLS IN
ARKANSAS, GRADES K-12.
SENATOR, ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE
PEOPLE OF YOUR STATE DON’T NEED
THAT MONEY?
>> Senator Cotton: CHRIS, THAT
BILL WOULD DO A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS AS WELL.
WE’VE BEEN TALK ABOUT WHAT
CAUSES BORDER CRISIS, LOOK AT A
COUPLE OTHER PROVISIONS IN OUR
BILL.
STIMULUS CHECKS TO ILLEGAL
ALIENS AS WELL OR MONEY TO
SANCTUARY CITIES.
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
INCENTIVES THAT HELP MIGRANTS
COME TO OUR BORDER.
MORE BROADLY THOUGH, WE WORKED
TOGETHER LAST YEAR WITH THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO PASS MULTIPLE
BILLS TO HELP THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE GET THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC.
MANY OF THOSE BILLS PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY.
WE DID ONE IN DECEMBER AS WELL.
THE CONDITIONS OF COURSE HAVE
CHANGED NOW.
VACCINES ARE SPREADING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, CASE RATES ARE
DECLINING RAPIDLY.
REPUBLICANS HAD NO PROBLEM
PROVIDING MORE MONEY FOR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION, FOR INSTANCE, OR
TO HELP PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST
INCOME, BUT WE SHOULDN’T BE
SPENDING $2 TRILLION ON A LOT OF
UNRELATED DEMOCRATIC PRIORITIES
OR SENDING MONEY TO FAMILIES
THAT HAVEN’T LOST ANY INCOME.
THAT’S WHAT THIS BILL DID.
>> Chris: HERE IS ONE OF YOUR
OTHER COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE COVID
RELIEF BILL.
TAKE A LOOK, SIR.
>> LOOK CRAZY SOME OF THE
DEMOCRATIC IDEALS ARE.
THEY HAD A CHANCE ON SATURDAY
MORNING TO STOP IT FROM GOING TO
PRISONERS, FROM GOING TO THE
BOSTON BOMBER, FOR INSTANCE AND
ON THAT NOTE THEY DECLINED.
EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRAT WANTED TO
CONTINUE THE PRACTICE OF SENDING
CHECKS TO PRISONERS.
>> Chris: BUT SENATOR , UNDER
TWO PREVIOUS COVID RELIEF BILLS
THAT YOU SUPPORTED AND VOTED FOR
AND THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED,
PRISONERS ALSO GOT CHECKS IN
THOSE BILLS.
>> Senator Cotton: WELL,
CHRIS, THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY NEVER
CONGRESS’ INTENT.
THE TRUMPET MR. RISCH AND, IRS
AND TREASURY DEPARTMENT DID NOT
SEND CHECKS TO PRISONERS,
LIBERAL ADVOCACY GROUPS SUED, A
JUDGE SAID THEY HAD TO.
LAST MONTH -- THIS MONTH WAS THE
FIRST TIME WE EVER HAD A SIMPLE
UP OR DOWN VOTE ON WHETHER THOSE
CHECKS SHOULD GO TO PRISONERS
AND THE SIMPLE FACT IS THAT
EVERY DEMOCRAT VOTED TO KEEP
SENDING CHECKS TO PRISONERS.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S A SMART
IDEA, I SUSPECT MOST AMERICANS
DON’T EITHER.
>> Chris: ONE OF THE NEXT BIG
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS WORKING ON IS
GOING TO BE AN EVEN BIGGER
2 TRILLION, 3 TRILLION,
$4 TRILLION INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN,
AND I WANT TO LOOK AT SOME OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT
ARKANSAS HAS.
4.9% OF THE BRIDGES IN ARKANSAS
ARE STRUCTURALLY DEFICIENT.
193 DAMS HAVE HIGH HAZARD
POTENTIAL.
DRINKING WATER NEEDS IN YOUR
STATE, $7.4 BILLION.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WANTS TO PAY FOR
THIS PLAN AT LEAST IN PART BY
RAISING TAXES ON PEOPLE MAKING
MORE THAN $400,000 A YEAR AND TO
RAISE THE CORPORATE TAX RATE
FROM 21% UP TO 28%.
WOULD YOU SUPPORT -- I MEAN,
AREN’T THE NEEDS IN ARKANSAS
SUFFICIENTLY URGENT THAT YOU
COULD SUPPORT TAXING PEOPLE
MAKING MORE THAN $400,000 AND
RAISING THE TAX RATE ON
CORPORATIONS, WHICH IS STILL
LOWER THAN WHEN -- WOULD STILL
BE LOWER THAN WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME INTO OFFICE
TO PAY FOR THAT?
>> Senator Cotton: CHRIS, WE
HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS IN
ARKANSAS, LIKE EVERY STATE DOES,
BUT I SUSPECT BASED ON WHAT
EFFORT MY DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS IN
THE SENATE THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
GOING TO BE GEARED TO ALERTS
THOSE NEEDS, IT’S GOING TO BE
GEARED TOWARDS BIG TAX INCREASES
END UP LAMENTING SOMETHING LIKE
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
IF YOU THINK YOUR GAS BILLS HAVE
GONE UP A LOT RECENTLY, WAIT
UNTIL YOU SEE WHAT YOU PAY AT
THE PUMP AFTER THE DEMOCRATS DO
THAT.
WE CAN DO THIS KIND OF BILL
WITHOUT BIG TAX HIKES.
THE REASON WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
AN INFRASTRUCTURE BILL RIGHT NOW
IS THAT THE LAST BILL WE PASSED
IS ABOUT TO EXPIRE INTO THIS
YEAR AND WE PASSED THAT BILL IN
2015 WITH MORE THAN 80 VOTES IN
THE UNITED STATES SENATE,
WITHOUT TAX INCREASES BURIED
WITH FOCUSED ON A LOT OF THE
PROBLEMS WE HAVE WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THIS COUNTRY,
LIKE EXCESSIVELY BURDENSOME AND
LENGTHY AND CUMBERSOME
PERMITTING AND REGULATORY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL APPROVAL
PROCESSES.
CHRIS, YOU PROBABLY KNOW THAT
THE PENTAGON WAS BUILT IN 16
MONTHS IN THE 1940s.
IT TOOK THE GOVERNMENT YEARS TO
REPAIR A BRIDGE IN FRONT OF THE
PENTAGON THAT JUST RUNS A COUPLE
HUNDRED FEET.
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE IN
THIS COUNTRY IS NOT THAT WE
DON’T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT’S THAT IT COSTS TOO MUCH AND
THAT WE SPEND TOO MUCH ON THINGS
THAT ARE NOT ROADS AND BRIDGES
AND BROADBAND ACCESS.
>> Chris: RIGHT.
FINALLY, I’VE GOT ABOUT A MINUTE
LEFT HERE, SIR, PRESIDENT BIDEN
TALKED THIS WEEK ABOUT TRYING TO
REFORM, NOT END, BUT TO REFORM
THE FILIBUSTER SO THAT SENATORS
HAVE TO KEEP TALKING AROUND THE
CLOCK IN ORDER TO CONTINUE THE
FILIBUSTER AND TO STOP THE
LEGISLATION.
TAKE A LOOK AT PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> President Biden: I DON’T
THINK YOU HAVE TO LIMIT THE
FILIBUSTER, YOU HAVE TO DO IT
WHAT IT USED TO BE WHEN I FIRST
GOT TO THE SENATE AND YOU HAD TO
STAND UP AND COMMAND THE FLOOR.
ONCE YOU STOP TALKING, YOU LOST
THAT AND SOMEONE CAN MOVE IN AND
SAY I MOVE THE QUESTION OF.
>> Chris: THERE HAS BEEN AN
EXPLOSION AND FILIBUSTERS.
357 CLOTURE MOTIONS TO END
DEBATE, MANY OF THEM NOT
SUCCESSFUL BUT 357 BETWEEN 1975
AND 1992.
SINCE 1993, 1,803 CLOTURE
MOTIONS AND AS I SAY, MANY OF
THEM DIDN’T END THE FILIBUSTER,
THEY WERE JUST ATTEMPTS TO
BURIED SENATOR, AT SOME POINT,
MAYBE AS SOON AS TWO YEARS FROM
NOW, YOU REPUBLICANS ARE GOING
TO BE BACK IN THE MAJORITY.
ISN’T THERE SOMETHING TO BE SAID
FOR MORE LEGISLATING AND LESS
GRIDLOCK?
>> Senator Cotton: NO, CHRIS,
THERE IS SOMETHING TO BE SAID
FOR COMPROMISE AND
BIPARTISANSHIP AND RESPECT FOR
THE RIGHTS OF THE MINORITY IN
THE SENATE BURIED THESE RULES
HAVE BEEN IN PLACE SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF OUR REPUBLIC AND
THE DEMOCRATS ARE ENGAGING IN
PRETTY HIGHLY SITUATIONAL
ETHICS.
FOUR YEARS AGO 27 DEMOCRATS
WROTE A LETTER URGING
MITCH McCONNELL AND
CHUCK SCHUMER TO MAINTAIN THESE
RULES.
MOST OF THOSE SENATORS HAVE
FLIP-FLOPPED SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE BAREST OF MAJORITIES.
REPUBLICANS REFUSED TO CHANGE
THOSE RULES FOUR YEARS AGO
BECAUSE WE RESPECT THESE
TRADITIONS IN THE SENATE AND WE
KNOW THEY’VE HELPED FORGE
DURABLE, BIPARTISAN CONSENSUS
LEGISLATION.
>> Chris: SENATOR COTTON,